gráficos muy buena estar con todos
ustedes mi nombre es elías cuestas y en
el tema de hoy es clase divertida clase
aprendida y si voy a hablar la
diversidad no puede faltar el pacman
bueno ya sabe mi nombre tengo 23 años de
edad soy del distrito más poblada de
latinoamérica san juan de lurigancho
y
hay algo que no mencioné la reseña pero
no los culpo porque yo no he puesto eso
porque no sé cómo lo van a tomar ustedes
repente se ha viendo un poco de mí pero
también soy modelo
porque se ha visto
y 285 la verdad que no sabe quizá poder
por la voz
ritmo romántica tu radio de baladas
pero no soy músico del modelo acá pueden
ver
del último trimestre cuando estuve en el
colegio de las flores y tuve promedio 17
30 las notas más bajas
16 preguntar detalles
pero la devaluación va de 0 a 20 cierto
alguna vez alguien de aquí ha sacado 21
en su libreta
pero si tengo un 21
incluso no está en la computadora y fue
el curso de lenguaje
pero la verdad que soy profesor de
matemáticas y soy uno de los profesores
más serios del medio
qué pasa
jajaja
gracias gracias y puedo humildemente soy
un mejor profesor de matemáticas
y usted dirá dónde quedó la humildad
antes que te retires del evento porque
soy muy egocéntrico déjame explicarte a
qué me refiero
yo parto del aprendizaje soy el mejor
profesor del mundo para poder dar lo
mejor de mí a mis alumnos y lo creo que
se merecen lo mejor eso hace que cada
día tengan nuevas ideas de vídeo que voy
a hacer o tenga de las formas de enseñar
y esos aquellos resultados quiero
como estadístico tengo que la tarde con
datos yo buscando agarrando de
diapositivas para acá para ti puse como
frases cubren de cuántas maneras sería
donde hablan y aparece un artículo en un
medio local en su página web en
tendencias y descubrí que ese mes pasado
y yo teniendo de ello no quiero hablar
porque mismo dice exactamente ustedes
ven ahí la parte subrayada dice que
muchos consideran que el que sale en el
video es uno de los mejores maestros que
ha visto todo
aparte de eso tengo que demostrar los
comentarios que a diario recibo
y si algo y una foto del perfil de palma
te dice que eres un crack te dice y es
gran profeta y está previsto que haya
más profesores como tú
en serio a diario recibo un montón de
comentarios
viene por el profe que estaba bueno que
el pan
este comentario lo digo en la exposición
se han escapado pero hay unos pocos
comentarios de que tengo y quiero que
recuerdes muchos sé que hay muchos
atendidos en el colegio
un profesor de matemáticas aburridos o
una clase que tenga 10
y quiero que reflexionemos en este
momento
porque es una clase de matemáticas puede
tornarse aburrido paso explicando los
factores que he podido ver
cuando era estudiante y ahora que estoy
en el mundo de la docencia detecta dos
factores primero la falta de vocación
siempre lo dicho y siempre lo diré si no
naciste para enseñar mejor de enseñes
segundo algo que esté llamado herencia
cultural el que ahora es profesor de la
temática en cuánto tiempo fue estudiante
es cierto pero tiene formó un profesor
de éxitos pasados
y quizás de enseñó de manera unidad y él
cree que enseñar matemáticas debe ser
aburrido
cuando no es así realmente
factores económicos una realidad que
vivimos a diario la gente
en el producida en toda la américa es
que la labor docente no está muy bien
ponderada
y esto creo que debe cambiar porque a
veces hablamos de los mejores objetivos
de otros países del mundo pero averiguar
cuánto ganó en sus profesores que es
filtros a él para que sean docentes y
vas a encontrar que solamente enseñan
los mejores profesionales del medio no
cualquiera de profesores en esos países
la prioridad sobre todos los profesores
que entienden mucho más tiempo enseñando
cree que como él enseña así debe ser
y nadie puede cambiarlo en esta primera
razón
o de la amazonía porque muchos
estudiantes para ir al colegio aburridos
porque ya saben que tienen que
levantarse temprano
straka lado laporta la asistencia
levanta la mano en la clase
en el recreo
pero ya sabe qué va a pasar no hay algo
que me motive a lo que le pase algo que
sea nuevo
este salto grave que ocurre en las
tablas que es si es algo que realmente
sabes qué
debes generar interés el famoso profesor
de fiscal en haití walter ley decía que
era un crimen aburrir en una clase
y yo lo compres ayer
y bueno el último que él ha llamado es
que se hablan distintos
el adolescente de ahora es un nativo
digital está al tanto de las nuevas
tendencias de negocio to bears es más
honesta de conseguir a gamers y si tú no
sabes el idioma que ellos hablan no vas
a poder generar un ambiente grato en el
aula
ahora bueno
ya vemos tips como docente que yo lo
puse en clases y son tres reglas de aula
que en realidad son 4x
primero respeta el respeto es la base de
interacción social ya que este usamos
una frase muy conocida que es respetos
guardan respetos
segundo le digo a los alumnos que
desarrollan su imaginación
si tú eres profesor de historia y
consigues trasladar a la época medieval
hablando de eso
para hacer que nos interese y lo otro es
que escucha algo que me gusta
de la labor del profesor es que yo
aprendo día a día de mis alumnos
cada uno de ellos es un universo
distinto ya veces hay que poner una
pausa en el salón de clases para
escucharlos
y porque esos tres reglas que son cuatro
de las iniciales ríe
y eso es cada aula pero dentro de frente
en vivo las reglas son estas prohibido
no reírse
esto es esencial
consigues al inicio hacer reír vas a
hacer que se quiere enganchar a través
del final es más va a quedar quieto
entonces vamos voy a explicar
algo llamado por hecho la plataforma
para patentar memento enseñar
como que es hora de tarde primero unas
características
es que todos este x 6 debe ser primero
didáctico que tiene que ver con la
capacidad de dejarse
segundo debe ser ocurrente aprovechar
situaciones cotidianas de la obra o de
la realidad nacional para cautivar con
el contenido de su enseñanza
carismático cuando hacemos un carisma
natural es obvio pero otros pueden
desarrollar las habilidades blandas y
hacer que las clases sean más amena
entusiasta y es a lo que acabe nos
aconsejamos para venir aquí a hablar a
té es si tiene cualquier otro problema
con vida de eso y está al habla con
todas las ganas de transmitir tu mensaje
si tú estás desanimaba al salón de
clases del profesor que el alumno ya ha
perdido sentido
números o tienes que atar de marcar
diferencia sigue las tendencias ya que
está de moda
haz cosas pilotos no se animen a hacer
tecnológico es importante el docente de
esta parte del siglo donde está de moda
las aplicativos móviles y toda la
tendencia tecnología debe manejar estos
conceptos de tecnología
y por último tiene que ser un experto tu
puedes copiar del chiste pero por no
saber matemáticas si algo te pregunta
algo y fuiste tiene que dominar tu tema
para que puedan su chiste tener sentido
y que las motos no crean que eres un
payaso nada más tienes que ser alguien
experto y tener puesto fácil escuchar
demotecnia
tras las iniciales docente
pues ahí quedó grabado los ejemplos que
hablan del centro tradicional por
ejemplo a un problema de escritorio
de novedoso pero somos cerrados que es
una foto es una captura de pantalla de
un vídeo que llorar y canal y queremos
ejercicio que decía si ella más amor es
nunca
calcular y dibujado el corazón de la
pizarra es más ella y de fondo de que
estaba nada la pizarra y el brazo
este vídeo
y
por eso un ejemplo en química por
ejemplo
tradicional los elementos del 6 el
oxígeno
me gusta bastante porque va a hacer
y se oyó sufrido seguro te dejo pobre
ofrece color
alcántara salidas al constatar de
repente viene esa carencia
y acá por ejemplo es física
y recuerda
[Música]
que había primeras segundas tres leyes
de la primera línea de inercia estos
conceptos que no tienen nada de novedoso
pero que quede grabado aprendas a las el
día de hoy lista
mira al reposo continua no se mueve no
pueden caminar si no hay la fuerza que
no nueva este cuerpo en reposo seguirá y
de ello no es esta la primera en la
escuela debemos estudiar la ley
gracias
[Aplausos]
cuesta
algunos consejos es que usó recursos
tecnológicos
y me gustó mucho
a parte de dinero de costo juntar el
dinero para pagar la vida
para poder pagarlo pero ahora lo
bastante
que está en el colegio mayor secundario
presidente la república la prepare para
mí crecer y ahora está en secundaria y
va a darte examen de haití o vacía
internacional y sus ejercicios de
probabilidad que les puede enseñar y
luego el ipad y me lo piden esto es que
yo consigo transformar
una pizarra
y así fue
está ahí está conectado a la televisión
y transformó tu televisión en una
pizarra desean invertir mucho
y hay una parte de un aplicativo móvil
que dije pero yo soy cofundador del
índico
y esta lo que busca es observar que el
aprendizaje colaborativo tiene sus
ejercicios que no te salen a ganar
celular tomas fotos al problema que
donde sale se sube al aplicativo móvil y
todos los usuarios estamos registrados
nos notifica que un nuevo problema se ha
subido para poder ayudar
sigues no estoy acá de la una
y acá voy terminando y quiero compartir
de un pensamiento que es muy importante
para mí y es que los sueños sí se hacen
realidad pero
de la radio
yo te digo que soñaba estar en un evento
que
y yo creo que estoy exponiendo
un sueño sería hablar de la disposición
y ahora estoy acá en realidad
pero no es tan fácil de ver aquí
dice no basta sólo con soñar los no sean
como muchos de mis alumnos que llegan
tarde al colegio es el profesor tengo
muchos sueños pues vengo tarde
eso haría que yo comparto 10
sino también porque la diferentes sueños
y mentales quizá se comía el poco más
fácil de alcanzar pero es algo un
poquito intransable difícil
entonces hay que construir un puente que
nos lleve a alcanzar esos sueños
quiero hablarte si estoy acá es por qué
de un deseo en allá
yo pedí con mucha fe y el siguiente
personaje que voy a mostrar
s
acá vemos a jesús ese llanto para más
y mucho me pregunta qué ejemplo de
maestros
y a lo que servían las personas sean
creyentes cuando es que jesús también se
le conoce como el maestro
y él me gusta su forma de enseñanza
la parábola es la narración sinfónica
que usar actividades cotidianas que en
ese tiempo la gente voy a comprender el
mensaje
porque los días religiosos harán vivir
más complicado para entenderlo y jesús
romper esquemas innovó dice
e hizo que las personas puedan
comprender lo que quería transmitir les
habló en su idioma
es esta que es muy conocida ustedes
saben mucho de semana santa
y en la escena de la adúltera
es que este esta escena
tu puedes hacer una analogía donde la
mujer adúltera puede ser el estudiante
que el sistema lo cataloga como
fracasado
los fariseos está ahí en educación el
profesor aburrido
tus exámenes pues todos antes de avanzar
vamos a seguir al que aparte
yo me estoy sumando y yo sé que ustedes
y
acá de lo que haga lo que él le da una
oportunidad de esta mujer y le dice a
uno
sí
visitando km y es más de tratado casos
que algunos profesores esto quisieran
enseñar he podido hacerlo y he podido
tener resultados porque trato de
limitarle ahí y quiero terminar con una
frase que yo siempre le transmita mis
alumnos porque ellos me dice el profe
quiero ser ingeniero de la unipol por
esto
trata de plata con cancha
y le digo esto que estudies
si no vienes para servir no sirve para
mí
siga los demás que los demás necesitan
de apoyo
en esta ayuda
se identifican conmigo porque también
con vestidores de la universidad han
dado alguna clase de domicilio de
matemáticas
y conoce en este rubro
el canal de un proyecto muy ambicioso
y no tengo ningún fin lucrativo lo que
yo busco es acortar la brecha que existe
entre él
y el nivel exige a su universidad para
ingresar apoyen en esto fue una charla
de elías cuestas el mejor profesor de
matemáticas del mundo gracias
[Aplausos]